17 millions d'euros pour créer plus de
80 itinéraires cyclables sur toute
l'agglomération grand paris seine et
oise c'est le projet du plan vélo validé
par la communauté urbaine
trois axes sont prioritaires d'ici 2025
d'abord la scène à vélo la future vélo
route qui doit relier paris au havre
passe par les yvelines
ce sont un million de cyclotouristes qui
sont attendus chaque année des
aménagements dérives sont prévues
j'ai aussi donc un levier de
développement économique touristique
donc donc la scène à vélo sur d'antiques
abbott une rive de la seine à l'autre
qui est alterne parfois rivaux à trith
bouge sur notre territoire
non on n'a plus de 60km deux itinéraires
le long de la seule deuxième volet du
plan vélo sécurisé les pistes et
itinéraires cyclables autour des lieux
de l'enseignement comme par exemple les
collèges ou les lycées les scolaires
pourront emprunter ou des nouvelles
pistes entre leur domicile et leur
établissement et des c2c de renforcer et
de sécuriser des deux itinéraires de
fête embraque nos enfants parfois le
long des départementales parfois à
travers champs enfin troisième point le
stationnement cyclable indispensables à
la pratique du vélo chaque année 500 à
1000 nouvelles places seront créées
autour des grands équipements et dans
les quartiers commerçants début des
travaux en 2022 et la scène à vélo
devrait-elle être inauguré en septembre
prochain